so I think that I could be mistaken but
I believe you had more dialogue in this
movie than your entire career put
together am I wrong
pretty close I had quite a bit of
dialogue in The Gambler I had some
pretty lengthy speeches and monologues
in that movie but what I said to Pete
Berg yesterday every single one of those
monologues that I had in this movie were
literally half of them were cut out of
the movie so I said to him and I had so
much dialogue that I literally like I
was on punishment had detention in
school and had to write something down a
hundred times I would write each each
speech down five times a day in the
beginning of the day and the end of the
day to be able to memorize these and he
cut them in half so I said to him I said
now every time you write a monologue for
me I'm literally just kind of cut it in
half I'm not learning all that stuff and
he's like he that was the one thing that
he was waiting for me to say but I think
for the sake of the pace of the movie
and everything else I thought we wanted
to make sure that we created a really
cool world and cool characters and you
invested in them so a character-driven
action movie so it's all character
character character story until the
action starts so that being said I
didn't give him any crap I mean I said
that and that was it normally I would
have been much more upset will these was
it like a much longer cut in the Edit
where we're gonna see a lot of this
unlike the blue right or is it stuff
that we're never gonna see um I think
it's worth putting it on the blu-ray for
sure I think there's a lot of stuff that
didn't make it into the movie um but I
think he did a really good job of
keeping up the pace but also making sure
that for certain people if it's hard to
follow they're still kind of
understanding what's going on and still
be able to absorb the information even
if they missed it the first time there's
a callback to something as long as it
didn't fall the big twist
completely um I am a big fan of when you
and Peter work together so I need to
know what's the next three projects what
are you doing well I know the next one
we're doing a thing called Wonderland
that Brian Helgeland
there's not a talented writer at all not
not at all
we sat in the room like giddy giddy
school kids me and Pete as we were
talking about all these ideas of
creating this whole world and the ideas
were just absolutely amazing Pete called
me about the scene that he had just come
up with and I was like oh my god
insane I'll tell you about it as soon as
the camera stopped rolling I was gonna
say yeah so I have a few fun questions
for you when I call fun we're gonna see
and I already have one minute I'm gonna
go through these quick what TV show
would you love to guest spot on guest
star on uh Barney Miller what that is a
unique one do you have a favorite sci-fi
or fantasy film uh yeah 2001 Space
Odyssey and I'm not a big safe sci-fi
guy what films scared you as a kid
Exorcist in Jaws uh
my jaws my dog just watched jaws and she
laughed about it he's the dad it's not
scary it's funny you should take her to
the mech yeah would you maybe opening
the safe don't take her to the Meg uh
what do you collect uh
shoes watches boots
vallabha Quinn swim trunks like I have
weird stuff that I could like golf shoes
golf clubs cars tons of stuff this
brings me my other thing I've been
asking everyone what's the most you've
spent on sneakers or shoes I've heard
from $50 to 2000 yes but I'm going to
there's a couple of pairs that are
coming up on auction so every time you
do a jordan branch shoe like I have a
new shoe that they made for me so we're
gonna donate a lot of them in auction
them off to charity the M&M car horns I
think the one for up to like 14 15
thousand dollars maybe maybe that's even
lowball in the number could have been
more than that so will that we'll see
but you know it's great cause so to be
able to raise money for that and for me
personally shoes I don't I don't really
care what the prices my wife gets lasted
me because I have more shoes my closet
is filled to the point where it just
looks like clutter and I have more shoes
than her that's amazing I could go so
deep on this I gotta go I'm gonna say
congrats and I really do hope you and
Peter are doing something
you